a very important essay by the German
philosopher Martin Heidegger is his on
the essence of truth and like some of
the other essays that we would see as
being particularly central it pulls
together a number of different themes
that you see as central and Heidegger's
work among one of which is this Greek
word Alafaya which we'll talk about in a
few moments but also the notion of doing
metaphysics history freedom getting away
from a sort of derivative or concealing
way of approaching things and the
connection between being and and beings
all of that is packed in here and we
want to try to unpack it in the course
of this essay one thing that you can say
about this is that you can see in this
both the Heidegger who is concerned with
you know the most broad general notions
that human beings would ever have to
grapple with what we call metaphysics
proper and with existential issues we
approach all of these things through the
lives that we live through the ways in
which we come to understanding of our
relationship with being and with beings
so we're going to talk about a number of
different ways of understanding truth
and this this essay is very much like
peeling an onion each time you peel you
think you that you've reached the center
no no no there's there's something more
yet to go so there's eight main sections
and we're going to try to work our way
through each of these there's also a
note at the end which I'm not going to
talk very much about now consider two
germane to what I'm trying to do here I
would like to say this part of where
we're heading is the notion of truth and
this is heidegger's distinctive
contribution among other things in this
this area as this Greek word all e-theta
you see the transliteration of this
below I'll lay Thea you know ah is the
primitive
and then lay Thea is coming from month
on along timing to to forget to conceal
to hide to overlook and so we can
understand
Alethea not only has truth it's a Greek
word for truth but also as the word for
linguistically or lexically
unforgettable akat it pops up several
times this essay
it also shows up in two other works that
I'd like to sort of call your attention
to very briefly being in time of course
and is basic problems of phenomenology
which is if you really want to get into
Heidegger that's I think that's one of
the texts that you you can't avoid
reading we're not going to engage with
these so they are now quite literally
out of the picture we're just going to
focus on this essay with the translation
by Salas and now we're going to dig into
it so he starts out saying all right
what is truth we have all sorts of
truths and truth we talked about popping
up in all different walks of life and
all different areas like he says
practical experience economic
calculation technical consideration
political suggested e scientific
research artistic composition thoughtful
reflection or cultic belief what
connects all of these together that's
what we want to ask about when we're
asking about an essence we want to know
not just what is truth in this area what
is truth in that area what is truth per
se he says from a common-sense point of
view this is seen as getting away from
any sort of specificity it's very
abstract and this is probably not going
to pay off for us to ask these kind of
questions
so he's Heidegger wants to contrast
common-sense ways of approaching things
from radical thinking going back to the
roots radical means going to the roots
so sound common sense
he says harps on the demand for palpable
utility in vain
is against knowledge of the essence of
things whose essential knowledge has
long been called philosophy and he says
common sense has something going for it
it works with what's obvious with what
is closest to hand but if you want to do
philosophy it's not to say that you
abandon common sense you just realize
that common sense is not your standard
for doing philosophy for getting behind
the appearances of things for getting
behind what's been concealed to it to
bring it to light
common sense is superficial it works
with the the top layer of things not the
depths so says in calling for actual
truth we must already know what truth is
such means on some level Heidegger
things that we already grasp to a
certain degree what it is for things to
be true for conduct to be true for our
minds to be true for our language to be
true but we were not yet articulating it
so he wants to start out with some some
basic ideas what's the usual concept of
truth he walks us through a kind of
three-part process he says the true is
the actual something is true when it
when it has actuality so for example he
says it's a true joy to cooperate in the
accomplishment of this task what does it
mean I'm actually experiencing joy and
we can talk about and he's got this
example of true gold gold is actual it's
something you can wrap your hand around
it's why people like it so much and we
can distinguish it from the false false
gold is something that might just be
painted gold or it's you know pyrite so
it looks like gold fool's gold we call
it and he says false gold is not what it
appears to be true Gold is it's false
Gold is merely a semblance thus is not
actual so we contrast semblance versus
action
right
always the actuality is true but doesn't
the fools gold of its own sort of
actuality it does have something it is a
being it is real so he says what is true
about genuine gold thus cannot be
demonstrated merely by its actuality the
question recursion Ewan and true mean
here so what is genuine gold we have
some conception of gold we have some
standard by which we say something is
gold or isn't gold
right so is this genuine gold is that
actual gold the actuality of which is in
accordance with what something with what
always in advance we properly mean buy
gold with the meaning with the notion
with the sense so what does it mean to
be a true friend well means to be in
accordance with some sort of notion of
friendship right
he says when we ever we suspect false
gold we say there's something not in
accord something doesn't died here we
would say in English stimmt nicht in
German it's it's the verb that he is
using on the other hand we say whatever
it is as it should be it is in accord
the matter is in accord is I escaped
however we call true not only an actual
joy genuine gold and all beings of such
kind but above all so and above all we
call true or false are statements about
thanks and this is where a lot of people
have wanted to locate truth and say
truth is not in beings and such truth is
in our statements about it it's not
we're saying like Thomas Aquinas wanted
to locate it's Thomas Aquinas very clear
truth is in the end
lect write statements represent things
that are that are in the intellect or in
the world and to that extent they can be
you know representative of truth but if
we look at modern times many people have
wanted to interpret truth is merely
being a property of statements now
that's kind of an interesting thing to
say so he says the true whether it's a
matter or proposition is what is it a
course what is a coordinate being true
and truth here signify Accord and thus
in a double sense the consonants of a
matter with what is supposed in advance
regarding it on the other hand the
accordance with what is meant in the
statement with the matter so he's he's
actually talking about a dual character
here dualism true I think if we actually
want to pay close attention we gotta
talk about three terms however and so
I'm going to put this up here because
we're going to make reference to this
over them the course of this is time we
have the matter or call it the thing
and we have some sort of thing with the
human mind intellect and then we have
language or state and there's some sort
of relationship between these there can
be this relationship of of concordance
or harmonization whoever you want to
translate given accordance is the the
translators choice their manners or
things you know can accord with the mind
our standards about things how do you
know something's gold you measure it by
the standards that you have how do you
know the things in your mind actually
map out of things in the world well you
know see what you've got in your head
and then see whether it maps not of the
stuff out there but we also have
language and there's a link here as well
because language is used to represent or
even to articulate what it is that we
have in our mind so these are three
things that are connected with each
other and they can they can come
together so he says the dual character
of the Accord here is brought to light
by the traditional definition of truth
better to us at Ida quad CRE and since
electus so the old-fashioned thing
here's the race and here's the
intellectus the and there's some sort of
relation on adequate Co an equation
equation and he says this can be taken
to mean truth is the correspondence of
the matter to knowledge but it can also
be taken to say truth is a
correspondence of knowledge to the
matter so we can go either way with this
and and Heidegger says they're not mere
inversions or the other on the contrary
in each case intellectus and race or
thought differently in order to
recognize this we have to trace the
formula back to its most recent that is
medieval origin Veritas at Ida quasi
array
intellect on an equation of things to
the mind does not imply the later
transcendental conception of con where
the mind is what sort of imposes order
on things rather what mind are we
talking about the divine mind it's for
somebody like Thomas Aquinas it's the
divine mind which is creative of all
things and things have their properties
and are what they are because their
ideas actually exist in the divine mind
which use those ideas as the model by
which to create them so high degree goes
on he says if all beings are created the
possibility of the truth of human
knowledge is grounded in the fact that
matter in proposition measure up to the
idea in the same way and therefore
fitted to each other on the basis of the
unity of the divine plan of creation so
if you've got God in the picture that's
one way to go you can say look divine
mind language our minds matter things
the weight of the world is map on to two
that I'm gonna skip ahead a little bit
he says if you want to get away from
this maybe you say well we take out of
the picture but do you really or you
substitute something else in there in
place as that which assures this this
concordance he says detach from the
notion of creation can also this order
can be represented in a general and
indefinite way as a world order and you
can do this with you if you're an
atheist you can do this if you're like
devoted to science you can do this from
all sorts of perspectives German
idealism the theologically conceived
order of creation is replaced by the
capacity of all objects to be planned by
means of a worldly reason which supplies
the law for itself and thus also claims
that it's procedure is immediately
intelligible or logical and this is the
great dream of the Enlightenment we
shall remake the world in the image of
man and make everything completely
rational and then totally knowable so
Heidegger thinks that that is actually
concealing something from
as well and he says the definition of
the essence of truth is independent of
the interpretation of the essence of
being of all beings which always
includes a corresponding interpretation
the essence of man is the bear and
executor of intellectus that's what's
wrong with these notions of truth they
leave human beings out of the picture
even when they're making human beings
you know so the central feature of it
they also ignore the relationship of us
to the being capital B of beings so
there's some untruth here there's a non
agreement of being with this essence
that's going to be a problem and he says
if we want to trace back propositional
truth to material truth and what in the
first instance it shows itself to be a
theological explanation and if we keep
the philosophical definition completely
pure of all it makes your theology limit
the concept of truth the propositional
truth then we encounter an old tradition
of thinking according to which truth is
the accordance voices of a statement
whether they logos with problem now
we're moving into Section 2 that's a
kind of strange thing to think about we
we have no problem understanding this
sort of thing when we're you know just
talking about it but if we look at it
and we pay close attention all sorts of
weird paradoxes arise consider two
objects actually I'll bring these back
in he talks about two coins let's talk
about two books right these are about
the same size
not completely close and there are
similar colors and stuff like that they
correspond to each other they're both
books but not the same book okay but
they correspond to each other in certain
ways right you can even say well the
relationship of these are that you
should read this one first and then read
this one first ma'am maybe so right now
go ahead and read this I don't just mean
read the words that are there read the
book
oh you can't because this is the book
right this is what actually has the
pages this is what actually has all the
you know thousands and thousands of
words arranged intelligently the
statement itself is not the thing is it
how does that statement correspond to
that thing this particular book and not
this book or not this coffee cup like
Heidegger says we want to consider coins
a linguistic statement about a coin it's
not made of metal it's not round it's
got nothing spatial you can buy stuff
with coins try buying something with it
with a statement about a coin I mean
give you a statement about $100 and
you'll give me $100 or the goods not
going to happen alright so what's this
correspondence then what is this between
them he says in spite of the
dissimilarity the above statement has
true is in accordance with the coin bump
statement being about the coin and
according to the usual concept of truth
this record is supposed to be a
correspondence how can what is
completely dissimilar the statement
correspond to the coin even you have to
become the coin that doesn't happen does
it and in this way relinquish itself
entirely it would no longer be the
statement he says the statement never
succeeds I'm doing that the moment it
did it would no longer be able as a
statement to be in accordance with the
thing it would be over here in this
realm
rather than being down here and then the
concordance he says the statement must
remain indeed even first become what it
is and that's a great way of saying it
it must become what it is we tend to
look at language as if it's something
fairly inert neutral it's just up to us
you know whatever we do with their minds
we make the lane
and that represents the things Heidegger
says correspondence here cannot some
signify a thing like approximation
between the similar kinds of things this
is a different type of being so what is
this correspondence here he talks about
this as
you talked about languages being present
'iv that's terrible
I'm an awful speller keep that very
present it presents the thing it doesn't
just represent it it offers a thing to
us it is what you might think it is like
putting out the handle there so that we
can actually make that thing a thing for
us so he says to be present here means
to let the thing stand opposed as object
to let it be something for us as this
place what stands opposed most
transverse an open field of oppose it
nests so now I want to erasure Nandu
Rhydian erasure those of you who get
that joke and we've got this recalls a
field of blue Cygnus which is
corresponding with the opening that was
very metaphorical language that
Heidegger likes to use hard to wrap your
head around I'm not sure that you
absolutely have to understand all of
this in order to make sense out of the
rest of what's being said here but I'll
put it on the board anyway so it's field
of openness now what happens here is the
the thing stands is a thing it shows
itself as something with standing as
remaining the appearing of the thing and
transversing a field of opposing is the
world of everything else including us
takes place within an open region the
openness of which is not created by the
presenting but rather is only entered
into and taken over as a domain of
relatedness so what is this relatedness
he says the relation of the present if
statement to the thing is the
accomplishment of that bearing for
helpless in German which originally it
always comes to prevail as a
here comes a key term comportment we
comport ourselves to things to other
people to the world as such to to
activities to to all sorts of things
that can be beings we comport ourselves
that means we not only behave we orient
ourselves we pay attention to some
things not to other things we have
intentions we want to get certain things
accomplished we we desire things that's
all part of what he's calling
comportment or for faire Halton so he
says all comportment is distinguished by
the fact that standing in the open
region it adheres to something opened up
and such what is opened up the things
what is opened up solely in the strict
sense was experienced really in Western
thinking as what is present and for a
long time the named being comportment he
says stands open to beings every open
relatedness is a comportment every way
of being in the world every way of
engaging things every kind of activity
were involved with or concern that we're
involved with is a way of being open to
beings it leads to a certain extent it's
also a way of you know hiding certainly
aspects of them but we we open up to
them you know I see this coffee and I
begin to desire it and I want more and I
taste it awakens for me memories
associations all those sorts of things
that is a way in which I'm becoming open
to to to being and he says man's open
stance varies depending on the kind of
beings in the way of comportment all
working and cheating all action and
calculation keep within an open region
within which beings with regard to what
they are and how they are can properly
take their stand and stand out as
opposed to us they can become things for
us we can notice them as objects in the
world and he says they can be spoken
now speech that directs itself
accordingly to the things is true what
is the sad is the correct the true so he
said a statement is invested with its
correctness by the openness of its
comportment and what's what's going on
here who's got it the comportment
statements human beings human beings who
talk actually have comportment the
statement by itself is just a puff of
air
really or a blot of ink he says only
through the latter can what has opened
up really become the standard for the
present of correspondents open core
comportment must let itself let itself
be assigned this standard so what's
going on here he says the traditional
assignment of truth exclusively to
statements falls away truth does not
originally reside in the proposition
where does it reside in comportment and
how through language we become related
in our comportment continually back and
forth to beings to things to the way
things are to the ways things are so
we've come a long way so let's look now
at section three what's going on with
this he changes the the ground now he
says to free oneself for abiding
directness as possible only by being
free for what has opened up within an
open region so what does that mean that
means that freedom and truth are
intimately connected that freedom is
part of the essence of truth
he says freedom is the essence of truth
itself now that's a problem
isn't it because we say freedom is at
the heart of truth or we say freedom is
of the essence of truth
what is it it to be a free being it
means you can do things all different
ways right you can you can choose so
doesn't that make truth very subjective
totally arbitrary up for grabs for
anybody who chooses to do whatever they
want I could have a win and say I think
truth is this thing over here no I think
it's this over here I can change my mind
whenever I want is that really what we
want by to mean by truth well that's a
problem
but he says truth is driven back to the
subjectivity of the human subject
there's two things that Heidegger says
here actually three things at this point
that are really key in this section
three first he he says look I gotta
admit there's a vulnerability of truth
he says the seat dissimulation lies and
deception illusion and someone's in
short all kinds of untruth are ascribed
to human beings but of course untruth is
the opposite of truth so truth in a
certain way in order to be truth he has
to contain within itself untruth or the
possibility of untruth it has to remain
continuously vulnerable to that which
allows which human beings can can bring
into being this way right I says it the
human origin of untruth indeed only
serves to confirm by contrast the
essence of truth in itself in another
way as holding sway beyond the end so
that's the first thing that he says he
says yeah look there's vulnerability
this is going to be a key issue in truth
the essence of truth is also going to
include its non essence okay so there's
that then what does he say about
traditional metaphysics he says
metaphysics regards such truth is the
imperishable and eternal which can never
be founded on the transitoriness and
fragility that belong to man's essence
how can the essence of truth still at
its substance and substance in its
ground and human freedom you know
traditional metaphysics Heidegger runs
through a lot of different types you
know platonic or silly
and Christian metaphysics coming about
you know through August II and all the
way through Aquinas Descartes you know
the Enlightenment can't even looks at
Nietzsche there's been a fundamental
issue of wanting truth to be something
that would be never up for grabs never
vulnerable immutable unchangeable
eternal greater than us therefore
because what can you say about us are we
or our minds or even our languages if
you know much about you know the history
of language immutable unchangeable no
way as a matter of fact we change our
minds way more often than we ought to so
we probably don't want truth to be
vulnerable in that sense there's they
says look this I can understand why
Plato wanted eternal forms the last
thing that he says is resistance to the
proposition that the essence of truth is
freedom is based on preconceptions the
most obstinate of which is that freedom
is a property of man we're not we don't
just have freedom hi dear ones to say we
are freedom we are in part that opening
space that that clearing so he says what
we have to carry out here and this is in
the fourth part is a transformation of
thinking this is consideration of the
essential connection between truth and
freedom leads us to pursue the question
of the essence of man in a regard that
assures us an experience of a concealed
essential ground of man it also becomes
evident that that freedom is the very
ground for what it is that we're doing
and the truth that we're experiencing so
what is freedom what is the essence of
freedom we now move from the essence of
truth to the essence of freedom what
does the freedom really mean Heidegger
is going to propose a new way of
thinking about freedom or perhaps an old
way that's now being better expressed he
says freedom reveals itself as letting
let's call the
now beings letting beings be what does
that mean he says well let's let's clear
away a few can misconceptions so let
beings be does not referred to neglect
and indifference doesn't mean just say
I'm not concerned with anything it's not
a withdrawal from from beings and from
the world and one's engagement says to
let be is to engage oneself with beings
so it's not quietism and then he says on
the other hand is that busybody ism what
we could call right it's not to be
understood as the mere management
preservation tending and planning of the
beings in each case encountered or
sought out where we subordinate the
beings to our song we say you're going
to fit this this schema because this is
what I want from you now that means to
in a certain sense respect them he says
to let be is to engage himself with
beings to let beings be as the beings
which they are means to engage with self
within the open region and its openness
into which every being comes to stand in
which a world forms for you bringing
that openness as it were along with
itself now here's where he first brings
up truth as Isaiah and undoing of the
concealments of the forgetfulness he
says this is the unconcealed if we
translate all I say is on concealment
rather than truth this translation is
not merely more literal it contains a
directive a directive to us human being
taking it all these things to do what to
rethink the ordinary concept of truth in
the sense of correctness of statements
and to think it back to that still
uncompromising Ness and disclosure
beings so we've come a long ways we have
been thinking about what does it what
does it mean for things to be true
originally we started out with wells
once it's
primarily about statements but then we
realized well statements are about the
things what is it for those things to be
to be true is it that they could form to
some sort of mind no as a matter of fact
we have to be willing to lend beings be
in our compartments in relation to them
and through that we have unconcealed
earnest truth things reveal themselves
to us as they are if we let them if
we're not trying to manage them and
we're not trying to say screw you I'm
not going to be engaged with you to them
so he says to engage oneself the
disclosed 'no sabaeans is not to lose
oneself in them so there's a third thing
that we're not trying to do here we're
not trying to say no I'm not going to be
involved with you we're not trying to
subordinate them to ourselves and we're
not also going to lose ourself in them
through some sort of fusion or mystical
you know ecstasy or something like that
he says rather such engagement withdraws
in the face of beings in order they
might reveal themselves with respect to
what and how they are and in order that
presentative correspondence my ticket
standards from them and this is what he
means been saying that human being is
ecstatic existence Heidegger is is
stressing the eck of that outside going
going outside of oneself and he says
freedom is not merely what common sense
is content to let past under this name
Caprice turning up occasionally in our
choosing and climbing in this direction
it's not mere absence of constraint nor
is it mere readiness for what is
required and necessary prior to all this
negative and positive freedom these are
different conceptions of freedom there's
a deeper sense of freedom engagement in
the disclosure of beings as such and he
says the accept the existence the the
being outside of just ones one's own
perspective one's own self being able to
allow beings to disclose themselves the
exsistance of historical man begins at
that moment where the first thinker
takes a questioning stand with regard to
the
concealment of beings by asking a key
question what is that key question that
has to be asked the most fundamental
question according to Heidegger what is
yeah what is being you talk about beings
we engage with beings we must know what
it means what is being what are beings
they says at first we look at this in
terms of fuzes or nature which here does
not get me in a particular sphere of
beings where other beings as such as a
whole history begins only when beings
themselves are expressly drawn up into
their own concealed and conservative
human beings history right um he goes on
and he says if existent design is a
human being which lets things be sets
man free for his freedom by first
offering to his choice something
possible and imposing on him something
necessary human Caprice does then not
have freedom at its disposal the notion
of freedom is just doing whatever you
want is not really freedom according to
Heidegger man does not possess freedom
as a property rather it is what human
being is it's best the converse holds
freedom existent disclosed of design
possesses man that's an interesting way
to think about it we don't possess
freedom freedom possesses us we move
around it we have our move you know we
have our being within it
so he says truth is disclosure of beings
through which an openness essentially
unfolds every mode of human comportment
is its own way open implies itself to
that towards which it comports itself
and the beings itself and it opens
itself up therefore for the truth of
those beings for what it is the day they
really are so he says however because
truth is in essence freedom historical
man can in letting things be also not
the beings be the beings which they are
and as they are so one possibility in
comportment is letting beings be the
other possibility and this is where we
have to get back into the essence of
truth a bit more is to be involved with
what he calls concealment semblance
comes to power so we have the essence of
truth and we've got several moments to
this disclose your beings openness
freedom human comportment right
what allows this to be is design human
being and its compartments right that
can go this way that can go this way to
these are equal possibilities so what is
this concealment hiding things from
ourselves
hiding the beings from ourselves so he
says in the not in it the non essence of
truth comes to the fore so he said the
non essence of truth cannot first arise
subsequently from mere human anatomy and
capacity and negligence the opposite of
truth truths dark shadow is there in it
and it's not like you know first there's
truth and then we come along and we
screw it up by choosing you know untruth
and on truth is just are not
corresponding to this no that's a
possibility for us and as a matter of
fact these are like in real life in real
compartment they're like locked up
together and we like shift from one to
the next very easily later on you'll say
we oscillate between the two of these so
he says untruth must derive from the
essence of truth only because truth and
untruth are in essence not irrelevant to
each other but rather belong together is
it possible for a true proposition to
enter into the point in opposition with
the corresponding untrue proposition
remember all again to go back how is it
that language represents how can it
correspond to things how can something
not correspond that because truth and
untruth are intimately intertwined so he
says okay that's that's a mind-blower
there right he says how are we to
comprehend the non essence in the
essence of truth
and he's not going to answer that in
directly now he's moving from part 4
part 5 and in part 5 he starts out
talking about attunement or it often
gets translated as mood in part 6 he's
going to talk about untruth is
concealing so let's see what he means
first in talking about attunement he
says so the essence of truth reveals
itself as freedom the latter is existent
disclose of letting beings be okay
that's we've gotten a parcel you know
along these lines
every mode of open compartment
flourishes and letting beings be in each
case is a compartment to this or that
being so it allows truth to be for those
right as engagement in the disclosure of
beings as a whole as such freedom has
already attuned all comportment to being
as a whole so there's a new important
thing it's no longer just two beings
it's two being as a whole so we attune
ourselves to being as a whole now what
does that mean he says being attuned can
never be understood as just experience
not just feeling we're missing its
essence if we do that he says its
interpreted on the basis of something
like live your soul that can maintain
the petal of essence only as long as it
bears itself a distortion so what is
being attuned for us says existence
exposing this to beings as a whole can
be experienced can be felt only because
the man who experiences without being
aware of the essence of the Tumen is
already engaged in being attuned in a
way that discloses being as a whole so
our feelings are our ways of
experiencing let's think about feelings
for a friend for a moment our emotions
heidegger really stresses anxiety oxd as
the the disclose of mood par excellence
think about how different the world is
for you when you're just ticked off
frustrated and and you know nothing
seems to be going right you see sides of
things that you didn't see before and
you're not happy
now think about the way in which you
feel when you're sad and not just sad
over something that happened that you
know maybe can't be repaired like
somebody dying but sad in a fuller
broader sense you and you experience
being as a whole in a different way a
kind of shrunken way but also a way that
sometimes you know to be melancholy and
I can tell you this from experience
opens you up to experiencing being
perhaps in some ways more fully than
than the happy-go-lucky person who just
sort of wanders around and everything's
okay for them now happiness or genuine
joy is another moment of disclosure of
beings reveals different signs to them
or think about gratitude something
Heidegger and talk much about frankly
but which some of Heidegger's followers
have talked quite a bit about if
gratitude is a mode of attunement to the
world it reveals beings in a different
way it reveals the truth of them so he
says every attunement the truman is
drawn up in beings as a whole the
openness of being as a whole does not
coincide with the sum of all immediate
familiar beings and here it gets to
something very very important
on the contrary where beings are not
very familiar to man and are scarcely
and only roughly known by science the
openness of beings as a whole can
prevail more essentially than a can
where the beat the familiar and
well-known has become boundless and
nothing is nothing is any longer able to
withstand the business of knowing
since technical mastery over things
bears itself without limit it's when we
put ourselves into the situation in
which we can let things be for us and
show they're there you're sides to us
that we think we know all about but
perhaps don't when we're able to
experience the mystery of life through
things to become deep open questions for
us and this is very is very existential
what he's talking about here
cuz it happens for a person this happens
for persons can happen on a larger scale
but it happens for persons experiencing
their world their sets of experienced
things their time what he calls their
thoroughness
so he says precisely in this the
openness of beings would get flattened
out if we if we just reduced everything
to what we know gets flattened out into
the apparent nothingness of what is no
longer even a matter of indifference but
rather simply forgotten we want to
unforgettable antis ism of why we want
to become like children we want to
become like children who aren't screwed
up who actually can like spontaneously
engage things but also have you know the
ability to have developed the ability to
engage things in a more resolute
persevering way as well so so letting
beings be which is an intuitive bringing
into accord prevails throughout and
anticipates all the open compartment
that flourishes in it so if we that's
what we do we flourish and being
flourishes man's compartment is brought
into definite chord throughout the
openness of being as a whole however
from the point of view of everyday
calculations and preoccupations this as
a whole appears to be incalculable and
in comprehensible you know when people
say yeah I want to think about I want to
think about even the meaning of life I
want to think about the whole big
picture we're often like that's fine but
you got to pay your taxes now or that's
fine but you know what time is it and
what do we got scheduled for for you
know you've got to go pick up the kids
now or you know that's okay if you want
to think about that kind of stuff but I
really just want to read this book and I
don't want to worry about the you know
like books as a whole or something like
along those lines we reject that and he
says this this is a mistake on our part
what brings into a chord is not nothing
but rather concealing of beings as a
whole precisely because letting be
always lets
beings be in a particular comportment
that relates to them and thus discloses
them so we know the truth of beings by
particular compartments which aim that
at the larger bigger picture thing of
you know sort of being as a whole beyond
these at the same time we introduced
concealment you can't have the one
provider without having the other we
conceal beings as a whole letting be
intra intrinsically at the same time and
concealing so let's go on now to section
6 which is really at the core of this
untruth as concealing as we're moving
into section 6 now on the essence of
truth what we're doing is we're moving
to much much larger scale larger picture
epochal metaphysics as Heidegger likes
to it likes to conceive of it and we're
getting away from the individual human
being and talking more now about like
truth in general falsity in general
being and metaphysics so he says what
we're going to look at now is the how
these are connected with each other
concealment and and truth as disclosure
or as yeah
and he says concealment deprives all the
Theia of disclosure but does not render
it privation stasis rather it preserves
what it is most proper to all FA as its
own what does that mean well that means
that within the very structure of human
being and it's compartments ORS
being and being there is always um some
disclosure and then there's always some
concealing so he says they can see them
in a being doing again is that that
basic point it's not something
subsequent it's not something secondary
it's there from the start the consuming
of beings as a whole does not first show
up subsequently as a consequence of the
fact that knowledge of beings is always
fragmentary it's not like we're ever
going to get away from this the
concealment of beings as a whole untruth
proper is older than every openness of
this or that being every comportment
involves this you can say it is older
than letting be itself which in
disclosing already holds concealed and
comports itself towards concealing and
here Heidegger is going to use the term
mystery kindness he says what conserves
letting be in this related relatedness
to concealing these these things nothing
less than the concealing of what is
concealed as a whole the concealed nasaw
what is concealed as a whole the very
fact that something is being concealed
is itself something that gets concealed
in the process something we lose sight
of something we forget about so that if
that happens and we don't suspect that
there's something there to open up to
try to get at the allah thea the the the
revelation there he says nothing less
than the concealing of what is concealed
as a whole that is the mystery now a
particular mystery regarding this or
that but the one mystery he says these
single overarching mystery as such that
in general mystery the concealing of
what is concealed as such hold sway
throughout man's design man's existence
man's being in the world and towards
towards beings so what is this
he says the proper noun essence of truth
is the mystery anyways what does that
mean okay well that means this is the
the essence of
to reveal to open up right also freedom
this is the non essence truth untruth
the non essence later on he will
actually call this the counter essence
of truth and I'll see the proper if not
essence of truth is it is the mystery
and this what's the what's the the
mystery how these two constantly go
along the non essence always remains at
its own weight essential to the essence
this isn't just playing with words what
he's saying here is if truth is
something that exists historically for
human beings and we have a role in this
and we have you know an essential role
in this it's not just something that
comes to secondarily then untruth is in
a certain way just as primordial as
truth and the non essence is essential
to the essence it never becomes uh
nacelle in the sense of irrelevant and
he says I understand this is paradoxical
this is hard to wrap your head around
this is something that is going to throw
you when I say it so he says surely for
those who know about such matters the
non of the primordial on essence of
truth as untruth points to the still
unexperienced domain of the truth of
being capital P not merely of beings as
letting beings be he says freedom is
intrinsically this resolutely resolutely
open bearing that does not close up in
itself that doesn't say okay we're done
we're finished here but he says
nevertheless this bearing towards
concealment conceals itself in the
process there's a forgetfulness that
we've lost sight of that we need
somebody to awaken us to say hey not
only are things concealed not only are
you missing out on stuff the big picture
of the fact that things are being
concealed has been concealed from you as
well and so he says how does this happen
well we take our bearings in our
compartment towards being
but for the most part we acquiesce and
this with that being in a particular
openness we allow the beings remember
how he said well we don't want to be
quietest and say and not not interested
in beings we don't want to try to just
dominate the beings we don't want to let
the but the beings dominate us we want
to stand back from them to a certain
extent if we don't stand back from them
to a certain extent then the beings end
up dominating us and they end up
concealing parts of themselves they were
not properly responding to them you can
say and they also conceal other parts of
beings so it says to reside and what is
readily available is intrinsically not
to let the concealing of what is
concealed hold sway if we stick with
what's too familiar with us we're going
to miss out on a great amount so he says
whatever the concealment wherever the
concealment of beings as a whole is
conceded only as a limit that
occasionally announces itself concealing
as a fundamental occurrence has sunk
into forgetfulness so again we have this
repression almost this this
forgetfulness of forgetfulness the
realization that were we've forgotten to
realize so he says the Forgotten mystery
of design is not eliminated by this
rather the forgotten us bestows on the
apparent disappearance of what has
forgotten a particular presence by
disavowing itself and in Adam for
forgetfulness the mystery leaves
historical man that is the kind of man
that we are the human beings in the
sphere of what is readily available - it
leaves them to his own resources so each
epoch in the history of metaphysics is
going to reach out for whatever it has
available to it not just in the beings
in the world but in its culture in its
conceptions in its own you know
possibilities for imagination it's going
to reach out for what's closest and say
AHA we'll understand being in terms of
this kind of beings we will forget that
there's something greater there's other
possibilities that we have left out so
like it says it humanity replenishes its
world on the basis of the latest needs
and aims and fills out that world by
means of proposing
planning from these man takes his
standards forgetting being as a whole
forgetting to do metaphysics doing
metaphysics but in a superficial less
well-informed way so he goes on and he
says you know human beings are always
supplying themselves the new standards
but without considering the ground the
foundation for taking up standards or
the essence of what gives the standard
and so thereby we go wrong we go astray
and this is where we get to now section
7 truth is Aron see he says as insistent
as like you know caught up in whatever
it is that we're doing with our projects
we are turned towards the most readily
available beings and in taking these
beings as our standards humanity is
turned away from the mystery the great
mystery the insistent turning towards
what is readily available and the X
system turning away from the mystery
belong together turning toward and away
from is based on a turning to and fro
proper to dowsing this is what he calls
Erik getting things wrong this is how we
fall into into this when we think we're
getting true theses man ears man does
not merely stray into Aaron see this is
integral so what it what it is to be a
human being brilliant way of thinking
about it we don't just make mistakes we
inhabit mistakes and they inhabit us
they pervade their way into our way of
relating to other things he says Aaron
sea belongs to the inner Constitution of
the design into which historical man is
admitted the kind of way of living as a
human being that we have as historical
beings like you know for example for us
late modern beings in a technological
society that's our way of being that's
our design
so he says Aaron C is the free space for
that turning in which insisted net
existence adroitly forgets and mistakes
itself continually inuvik in like
multiply itself
the concealing of the concealed being as
a whole hold sway in that disclosure of
specific beings so we're paying
attention to some things some some range
of beings and we're forgetting the rest
and we're forgetting the fact that we're
forgetting the rest so he says this is
the essential counter essence it's not
just the not essence it's the counter
essence to the primordial essence of
truth Aaron C opens itself up is the
open region for every opposite to
essential truth so he noticed openness
right freedom doesn't just mean freedom
to let beings be and disclose beings it
also means the freedom to screw things
up to take the wrong stance to go
slightly astray and then even more
astray and more astray so he says ear is
not merely an isolated mistake but the
realm the domain of the history of those
entanglements in which all kinds of
earing get interwoven it's not just a
matter of my going astray my entire epic
goes astray my entire culture goes
astray he says every mode of comportment
has its mode of error so this is
something that connects us together if
I'm involved in doing something and
you're involved in doing that something
too we have similar modes of error that
we can fall into even together and he
says error extends from the most
ordinary wasting of time making a
mistake miscalculating to going astray
and venturing in one's essential
attitudes and decisions however what is
ordinarily and even according to
philosophy recognizes this error in
correctness of judgments falsity of
knowledge is only one mode of airing we
tend to look at the error as if it's
something primarily intellectual
primarily and you know what's within my
head doesn't map on to what's out there
or I don't follow what's in my head
adequately right Heidegger is saying
that airing as an existential condition
has all sorts of modes it can be in our
feelings it can be in our actions it can
be in our relations to thing
it can be in the way we understand
things there's a lot of possibilities so
I said the Aaron C in which any given
segment of historical humanity must
proceed for its course to be errant is
essentially connected with the openness
of design by leading him astray Aaron C
dominates man through and through and
not only starts talking in terms of
oppression in terms of a kind of pushing
us down you know he talks about this in
terms of the mystery and he talks about
this in terms of Aaron see this is the
full essence of truth then includes its
most proper non essence and it keeps
design wavering between these back four
back and forth back and forth you can
never just remain within the truth
you're always going back and forth
within the greater essence of truth
which includes untruth inside of itself
it includes its opposite so he says the
full essence of truth including its most
proper noun essence keeps design in need
by this perpetual trimming and fro
design is a turning into knee that's one
of heidegger's most famous statements
design is a turning into need so he says
Aaron C and the concealing of what is
concealed belong to the primordial
essence of truth so truth itself right
the essence of truth itself includes
this includes its opposite includes its
its counter truth
so he says letting beings be as a whole
occurs in a way befitting its existence
only for one from time to time it gets
taken up into its primordial essence
then resoluteness openness as one
Heidegger's favorite rewards
resoluteness right towards the mystery
is underway into Aaron see as such then
the question of the essence of truth
gets asked once again more originally so
we're finally almost at the very inside
of the onion and he says the ground of
the intertwining of the essence of truth
with the truth of essence reveals itself
as Heidegger just playing with words
there and saying you know essence of
truth truth of essence you know like we
like to flip words around
not exactly he this is something he
doesn't follow up and we're not gonna
follow it up and this either because he
doesn't follow it up so I don't think
myself but he says what we're about is
trying to question the being of being
what it is that everything right we're
not just trying to think about beings
individual beings or ranges of beings
we're trying to think about the whole
shebang you might say not a technical
term there and he says the thinking of
being capital B from which such
questioning primarily originates has
sent splayed open understood his
philosophy later receive the title
metaphysics so Heidegger is saying if we
want to really you know understand this
if we want to think this all the way
through we had to do metaphysics and
that metaphysics just like trying to
tally up what you know what is out there
or you know trying to explain that we
have to try to think the whole we have
to try to thank everything including
truth itself and how truth takes place
and how truth includes untruth and how
that's connected to human subjectivity
that's a big issue big you know that's
hard to do so he says this is now we're
moving to section eight the very last
section before the note which I'm not
going to discuss because it's it's it's
something coming later and I think this
is good as it is he says in the thinking
of being the liberation of man for
existence the liberation that grounds
history is put into words
doing metaphysics we give language to
being we give language to being if
there's a back-and-forth we take our
cues from the beings that we let be so
to show themselves to unveil themselves
to us we are the creature the being that
cares about other beings so he goes on
today and he says when we're doing this
is falada in philosophy we're trying to
express something that
is very difficult to express and he says
something happens at the same time as
philosophy in the same period where the
beginning of philosophy takes place the
market domination of common sense and
then he puts in parentheses sophistry
takes way so common sense remember
common sense is superficial sophistry
appears to be a little bit deeper but
it's also equally superficial
he says sophistry appeals to the
unquestionable characters of beings that
are opened up and interprets all
thoughtful questioning as an attack on
an unfortunate irritation of common
sense but what philosophy is about is
actually you know trying to go beyond
common sense and he says the full
essence of truth contains the non
essence and above all hold sway is
concealing so philosophy is questioning
into this truth is essentially
discordant philosophy itself reflects
this back and forth philosophy itself is
not going to be something that's neatly
wrapped up in a bow provided to in a
book where you could have you know
Heidegger for dummies and design
existence truth Allah Theo we got it all
now I'll figure it out great now we go
on to do whatever we're going to do it
has to grip you you have to be willing
to live in that disc ordinance in order
to do philosophy like he says for
philosophical thinking is especially the
stern and resolute openness that does
not disrupt the concealing but entreats
it's unbroken essence into the open
region of understanding and thus into
its own truth he talks about gentle
Stern to stern gentleness involved in
philosophy
so he says philosophy becomes a kind of
questioning a process and that can
become a comportment notice philosophy
itself can become the comportment of
compartments and it becomes a
questioning which does not cling solely
to beings does not allow them to
dominate it but can says which a lot can
allow no externally imposed agreen he
says Kant actually got this right in
these respects so this essential view of
the determination of philosophy goes far
enough to renounce every subjugation
philosophical thinking
if the goal is not just to think beings
but to think the being of the being as
such and the ontological distance
between being capital B and lowercase B
philosophy cannot simply model itself
after the sciences it cannot be common
sense it actually has to open itself up
and then prepare for beings to talk to
it so he says in trait and here's where
I'm going to actually end he says in the
concept of essence philosophy thinks
being in tracing the inner possibility
of the correctness of statements back
into the X system freedom of letting B
as its ground there was our first
movement likewise and pointing to the
essential commencement of this ground
and concealing and inerrancy what we've
done here we want to show that the
emptiest essence of truth is not the
empty generality of an abstract
universality but rather that which self
concealing is unique in the unremitting
history of disclosure of the meaning of
what we call being doing metaphysics
what we for a long time have been
accustomed to considering only as being
as a whole and can lowercase B so we've
covered a lot of ground we've moved away
from our ordinary conceptions of truth
which we saw you know there's something
there but they're not able to explain
themselves there's something missing -
we have to probe deeper and we got we
want deeper we found out that truth is
actually connected not only to
attunement
and things thick you know fitting
together well but to freedom the human
freedom not just freedom as such but
distinctively human freedom and that's
freedom which exists in relation to the
beings that it allows to be so there's
this dialectic this back-and-forth high
degree of length or dialectic but I'm
going to say it dialectic between us and
the beings which we contribute something
to and they contribute something to us
and we saw that there is several
different ways we can approach this and
even when we do it
even when we're dead on with that we end
up in this paradoxical condition where
we realize that what is being revealed
there's still something being concealed
and the truth contains within itself
untruth and that's just integral to the
way it is and and that's not only a
matter of something out there that
actually comes into design itself that
is us our importance our ways of
relating to things Aaron see is not
something that we just sort of up I've
screwed up and I fell into it is part of
our condition and we want to avoid
falling into fairly Universal ways of
just sticking with Aaron C and losing
sight of what Heidegger calls the
mystery if we do that then we end up
inevitably starting to pose metaphysical
questions and not just questions that
we're liking out there you know looking
at encyclopedias for answers but
questions that motivate us to seek to
relate ourselves to being with a capital
B questions that have had some answers
given but which may not be sufficient
answers for us which Heidegger thinks we
need to think out anew so a lot of
ground covered here and that's where
we'll leave off